where the sisters brother we're good at
what we do huh we've had a good long run
we need to get out open the store
together store nonsense walk in the
front door and finish the job
all right you're not gonna like what
comes next open your safe no si FTE RFP
my sister's different many more employer
we have enough money stop telling people
realize that her father was struck
raving mad and we got a felt blood my
father drank charlie gentlemen I have
found him I will try to hold him until
your arrival make haste
hey is this warm have it's so
interesting
what's the great challenge that all
prospectors face how do I get the gold
just beneath my feet I told you I'm
chemist have you ever tested it I think
it's dead yes we're going to have to
fight is you're gonna notice eventually
you're gonna get it we're good at what
we do charlie
they were upset I'm leaving what's wrong
with him you hit me in public Charlie
after I slap you you slapped me back
Raven
so then hit me
you